what if kokoshibo fought against the
other upper moons in blood battles would
he be able to prove that he is the
strongest or is there someone who can
defeat him and take the title for
himself today we will be going through
all of kokoshibo's battles against the
upper moons and we even have a special
showdown at the end which you definitely
don't want to miss even as a hashira
kokoshiba was already extremely strong
as he had access to the transparent
world and selfless state he was the
second strongest ashira and could easily
kill scores of demons his breathing
technique moon breathing is the second
strongest breathing technique in the
entire series second only to sun
breathing as a human kokoshiba was
extremely jealous of his younger
brother's skill and strength he wanted
to surpass his brother and become the
strongest and he would do anything to
make that happen this deep hatred and
jealousy were what pushed him to become
a demon after his transformation he
quickly became immensely powerful and
occupied the position of upper moon 1.
if kokoshibo ever fought against lower
moons it would be a child's play for him
the lower moons are just too weak
compared with their upper moon
counterparts his mere presence would
send shivers down the spines of all the
lower moons as they would easily be able
to ascertain the vast difference in
strength just to paint a more vivid
picture the upper moons remained
unchanged for over a century they've
gone on to kill scores of ashira the
highest ranked demon slayers for
instance the upper moon 6 dhaki and
gyutara have killed 7 and 14 hashiras
and they are the weakest upper moons so
we can only imagine how many hashiras
kokoshiba must have killed meanwhile the
ranks of the lower moons constantly
change because they are always killed by
any hashira who crossed his paths with
them this fact angered muzon and made
him wipe out all the lower moons now the
real blood battles start let's see how
kokoshiba would fare against the upper
moon 6 daki and
as we all know is a weakling the only
reason she is an upper moon is because
of the special privilege muzon gave
gyutaro to also let his sister be an
upper moon with him daki would perform
terribly against kokushibo even though
she has managed to kill seven hashiras
in her lifetime kukushipa would still
kill her in one fell swoop this is
because most of the hasheras she's
killed can be attributed to the help of
her brother in fact when they were
decapitated by tondro in the anime
gyutero revealed that daki would have
been killed several times had he not
rescued her again this goes to show just
how weak she is there's just no way she
can hold her own in a battle against the
strongest upper moon in existence
kokoshibo as for gyotoro he may be able
to hold his ground for some time given
his agility and speed his poisons would
obviously have no effect on kokushibo
even combined both daki and gyotro can't
defeat kokoshibo they're the weakest
upper moons for a reason but would
kokoshipo be capable of slicing off both
of their heads at the same time this
could be quite bothersome even for the
great kokoshibo ultimately he would be
able to decapitate both of them at the
same time since his moon breathing
techniques are capable of sending
multiple attacks simultaneously after
kokoshipo finishes with daki and kyotoro
gyoko will be next in the line kyoko is
strong no doubt he was able to overwhelm
the miss tishira muichiro the first time
they engaged each other this feat is
really impressive considering that
moichiro is a child prodigy and one of
the strongest hashiras in the series
although gyoko had the advantage at the
beginning of the fight he quickly lost
once muichiro awakened his demon slayer
mark fast forward a few months later to
the infinity castle arc moichiro gets
the beating of a lifetime from kokushibo
even with his demon slayer mark awakened
in fact the battle was more of bullying
than an actual fight as kokushiba was
just toying with him and at the same
time effortlessly avoiding his attacks
let's take a logical look at this series
of events marked moichiro defeated gyoko
meanwhile the same marked moyichiro got
destroyed by kokoshibo with this it's
obvious that gyouka would lose in a
battle against kokushibo only three more
challenges are left and the next one is
hantengu antengu would most likely cause
the most headache for kokoshibo compared
to all the demons discussed so far
ultimately kokoshiba would win because
the difference in raw strength and power
between them is very significant but how
long would it take kokoshibo to end the
battle that'll probably depend on how
fast he is able to kill hantengo's
clones since that's one of the latter's
most powerful abilities being able to
create clones of himself each time he is
beheaded huntangu's strongest form
zohakuten is also incredibly strong as
he was capable of using it to battle
mitsuri even with her demon slayer mark
awakened he would probably be able to
stand against kokushibo without dying
immediately in this form but in the end
he would only be buying time and
focusing solely on defense this however
will not save him from the impending
doom that awaits him and at the end of
the day he will still be killed and
there's nothing he can do to avoid it
finally the battle that many fans wanted
to see in the anime but never happened
akaza vs kokushibo akaza is incredibly
strong perhaps just as much as he's
rebellious ideally this battle should be
different and more interesting as this
is the realm of the top three strongest
demons akasa is a martial artist who has
reached the peak of its physical
abilities his immense strength was
witnessed in his battle against rangoku
he basically kept playing with the flame
pillar until he killed him only getting
in slight trouble due to the sun rising
he also battled against giu and tangero
at the same time and he was able to
overpower both of them even though gu
activated his demon slayer mark it's
also important to mention that he and
kokoshibo are the only demons besides
muzon who became immune to decapitation
by nichiren swords with this the only
way to kill them would be to battle them
long enough for the sun to rise another
aspect of akaza's immense strength is
his ability to sense the fighting spirit
of his opponents this bolsters his
offensive and defensive capabilities and
essentially makes him invincible
kokoshibo on the other hand has been
capable of concealing his fighting
spirit ever since he was a human this is
because he gained access to the
transparent world and selfless state as
a hashira so even back then akaza would
find it incredibly difficult to sense
his fighting spirit it's crazy to think
that human kokoshibo already possesses
one of akaza's major weaknesses and that
the latter would probably lose a battle
against him even in his human form
essentially human kokoshibo is
comparable to akaza this means that
demon upper rank 1 kokoshibo would be on
an entirely different level to a kaza
and that he would easily be able to
defeat him let's for instance strip
kokoshibo of his ability to conceal his
presence he would still be capable of
defeating akaza with moon breathing the
second most powerful breathing technique
but he wouldn't accomplish this feat
without a few injuries injuries that'll
literally heal within seconds while
akaza remains dead we will soon cover
the ultimate showdown between kokushibo
and upper moons but before that we still
have one more upper moon to cover the
cult leader doma domo would definitely
be a challenging foe for kokoshibo we
don't know much about the extent of
doma's strength but he's the second
strongest demon in the ranks of the
upper moons and that says a lot how
would he fare in a bout against
kokushibo since we don't know much about
the extent of his strength let's take a
look at some of his feats domo was the
upper moon 5 when he turned daki and
gyotoro into demons thus it's safe to
say that he swiftly ascended into the
position of upper moon 2 since according
to what muzon said the upper moon ranks
have remained unchanged for the past
century this shows that he likely
surpassed some of the already existing
upper moons in terms of strength and
power thus getting him promoted to the
rank of upper moon 2. also he defeated
shinobu a hashira of the demon slayer
core with relative ease after which he
basically toyed with inusuki and canal
in the ensuing combat this shows that he
would prove a pretty troublesome
opponent for kokoshibo another testament
to doma's strength is that he was not
afraid of akaza's attacks and he
continuously irritated him it's sad
however that the full extent of his
power was not revealed the only time he
was about to get serious in battle was
when shinobu's poison began to affect
him but by that time it was too late as
he was already extremely weakened from
the effects of the poison overall the
fact that he is upper rank 2 says a lot
but despite all of his power kokoshibo
still remains the big boss of the upper
moons and he would still emerge
victorious in a battle against doma with
mid-difficulty
and now we are getting to the final act
the ultimate showdown doma and akaza vs
kokushibo despite being the strongest of
all the demons it'll be very tough for
kokoshibo to make it out of this battle
alive firstly it took three of the
strongest ashiras yome sunemi moichiro
plus genya to defeat kokoshipo split
into two there's no way these teams can
defeat doma and akaza in separate
battles even if they choose not to split
up there's no way this team of demons
players can defeat both doma and akaza
if they teamed up and fought side by
side at the same time yet they managed
to defeat kokoshibo akaza is already a
formidable foe and doma is even more
formidable hence as a tag team assuming
they would get along they would
definitely be able to defeat the upper
moon 1 demon the only entity capable of
defeating this duo would be the demon
king himself muzon and of course the
great yorichi tsugikuni check out this
video where we explained what would
happen if ran goku accepted akasa's
offer to transform trust me it's an
excellent video